regression analysis A regression
analysis makes it possible to infer or
predict a variable on the basis of one
or more other variables let's say you
want to find out what influences the
salary of people you could take the
highest level of Education the weekly
working hours and the age of a person
now you can investigate whether these
three independent variables have an
influence on the salary if they do have
an influence you can predict a person's
salary by taking the highest educational
level the weekly working hours and age
the variable you want to infer or
predict is called the dependent variable
or Criterion the variables you use for
your prediction are called independent
variables or predictors of course you
can also calculate your regression
online just visit datadeep.net copy your
data into the table and select the
variables that simple